how do you read and write to files and
C++ this is pretty important and I think
it's time to cover it so here we go I am
starting from absolutely nothing so I've
got just a cygwin terminal here and I'm
gonna make a directory called reading
data and I'm gonna go into that
directory and I'm gonna make a few files
with the touch command I'm gonna make a
make file a main dot cpp a and dot and
an end dot txt and now I'm just gonna go
ahead and open up visual studio code on
this folder and there we are
this is back directory whoops today's is
ok I'm going to open up visual studio
code on this directory close that one
and just expand this out to fit my
screen nicely now I am live casting this
so there aren't gonna be any edits but
I'll try to be quick and succinct as it
as much as I can but I think starting
from scratch is always nice this is from
the context of a Linux standpoint just
in case you're not sure but it is
essentially the same on Windows other
then you'll probably be using Visual
Studio the full normal version and just
you know pressing the Run button and
stuff but the commands in how you write
things is generally gonna be the same ok
so I'm just gonna get my little compiler
ready with a plain make file here and
we'll do a little more with that as we
need to and this n dot text now we kind
of kind of decide what kind of example
we're going to do
let me give me a little scenario here if
you want to save stuff for your program
you need to write it out to something
you just you need to write the data and
then read it back in later if you have a
big file from some other program that's
essentially a bunch of data at a process
you need to read it in so you might need
to do some special formatting within
your the way it brings it in and sorts
it out but in this end let's just say
we're given I'm just going to type some
random float values each on a new line
and we'll just do ten of them so bear
with me here but does zero there just to
fill that out and let's say we kind of
already know the format of these it is
semi important to know the format that
you're bringing them in so you're gonna
know based on your file whether it's a
JSON file or a plain text file where
everything's on a new line or it's
broken up into column somehow you often
look at the file and and take this into
account I'm not gonna worry about that
too much
I'm just gonna do a number on each line
in this case because that's a pretty
simple case and I really just want to
show the absolute basics of it so if we
want to read this in and do something
with it first we're gonna make it need
to make a a main here and I'll skip a
few lines here and just to well just do
a main in main and of course at the end
we're gonna return zero and if we just
want to read read that in and not
anything else we're gonna need a library
called if stream or I'm sorry am I doing
this wrong
F Street which stands for filestream so
that is the header that includes the
classes we need to read and write files
and we do have to declare an object to
handle this in that object we're reading
in is in a nice stream I say that right
I'm just doing a little research oh if
it's an if stream and I'm not sure if I
need Stanley let's see if it's happy
with that no it is it is standard okay
so there we go that's one of the nice
things about use as an editor is it'll
help you correct things if you're not
entirely sure and that can be pretty
nice so there we are with F stream and
we declare an if stream which is an
input file stream and that allows you to
read things in so basically what we do
is we need somewhere to store this data
because we could just do an dot now
let's see get line and get our data but
first we need to open our file so we do
n dot open and we path to our file which
is just in dot txt in this case now you
can declare it like this to open it
right away but we're not gonna do that
we're gonna open it second just to make
it a little clearer and you want to make
sure it's open so if you do this is open
this returns a boolean network it's true
if you have your file open and as false
if not so that way we can check we can
do that in an if statement if n is open
then we'll go ahead and process it so
let's say we want to we know it's some
amount of
of things on a new line but we don't
necessarily know how many so we want to
record how many way end up getting and
we'll do that with an integer you know
I'll just call it how many started out
as zero and we also want to record each
of these and save them as a data save
them as data in our program so that we
can do something with them and I'm gonna
do that with the vector class that I
went over last time so we can just
declare a vector and let's say we know
their floats so we can just say float
we'll just call it underscore data or
maybe I don't know we could say anything
we'll just say num data num data's fine
for number data or whatever you want I'm
gonna change that the file data it
doesn't doesn't matter that much but I I
feel like that makes easier sense so wow
it's open let's go ahead and do this so
what we want to do is we want to just
pull that in and save it to our our loop
so let's do it for loop and we'll say or
actually let's do a while loop and we'll
say wow n dot or not and in your file so
wow it's not the end of file and this
end of file flag well okay what happens
here is in your file when you're reading
it in when you attempt to read the last
line and there's nothing left it reads
in and in the file flag and it becomes
the status of an end of file so this
does keep track of a status of some sort
and when it is in the file it's gonna
exit our loop so while we're not at the
end of file we're gonna do some
processing and what we're gonna do is
we're going to
gonna do a get line so we'll say file
data dot pushback and then what we're
gonna push back is going to be in here
we'll say n dot get line
this isn't this so the best way to do it
I'm actually gonna declare a temp
variable here I they float attempt that
we just used to push back and we'll
start it out a zero and it will say Tim
equals and get line and am I doing this
syntax right maybe I need the temp in
there work less i i always forget the
difference between get and get line so i
need to look it up so i'm just going to
do a quick google here look at get line
okay get line saves it as a string so
what we might want to do instead i
haven't really talked about strings in
this series but they're basically arrays
of characters handled in their own
little library
and this could get a little complicated
but I want to try to keep it simple so
instead of using get line I'm just gonna
use the second thing you've been seen
but instead of CN it's just gonna be
this input file stream of n because the
console end and console out CNC out that
we've been using are very similar to
this except instead of going to a
console it's working with files so you
can use these same scope thingamajigger
x' or i'm not sure exactly what they're
called out my head here to pull in data
and to push out data to the file in from
the file and this one is specifically
input so if you try to do the out one
it's gonna show an error when you can
fly out so let's do and in and we're
gonna save it to the temp and now as
with just with the same with CN whenever
you press enter it stops your input and
it's going to be the same for this file
whenever you whatever it sees a new line
which will be at the end of these it's
gonna stop the input for that one so
this first one this n is going to take
everything on this line the problem with
get line is a reason it is a string so
then you have to convert it from a
string to your data type which is not
that hard but I don't want to get into
that just as of right now but as you get
more advanced it's very handy because
you often get a whole line at a time
process it pull the data out of it that
you want and then go forward this also
pulls the data out of it but it'll auto
convert it to whatever a data type
you're trying however if this had
characters in it like like so who knows
what we get it would become very awkward
if we tried to save that as float so we
get some strange things but since I know
for sure that it's a float value this
should be fine let's shrink these
numbers a tiny bit just so it
risk overflowing anything okay there we
go
so while not into file we're going to
grab this temp and then we're gonna push
it back onto our vector and we're only
gonna do that if it's open we'll put an
else case down here and we'll say we'll
just give a see out air of file not open
a new line there and for this C out to
be recognized of course we do need I Oh
stream and that's just a little error
notification and now to make sure this
actually works let's do a for loop down
here and spit out the data that we read
in just to confirm I is less than a file
data size and we'll do a plus plus I it
doesn't really matter if you do in these
four lives if we do plus plus I or I
plus plus you can look up the
differences if you want if you want but
it is not relevant in these cases and
let's go ahead and compile this oh wait
let's do a see out here of our vector
location so it'll be file data at
location I and then we'll do a new line
just so it splits the data into a new
line and up here we just paste this
again on if I it so it's gonna spit out
this one line before going to this data
read
and then it'll say the numbers below we
could optionally have commas here in
between them all I'll do with the commas
for now and let's go ahead and run this
so I'm gonna do a make it compiles with
no problems all right
and there's our data you know it cut off
some of these because they're so large
so maybe we're working a little too big
but it did read in all the data as
expected it looks like it grabbed a zero
at the end so we might have a bit of an
error case here where it's getting the
end of file a little bit sooner than we
expect or a little bit later than we
expect because it's grabbing this last
one and processing it as zero and that's
okay but we could make some fine
adjustments to make sure that doesn't
happen let's also put in here just the
size of our vector because it should be
I'm just I'm not trying to click that ah
precision clicking not on point let's
say size of data you know say size of
data and we'll just spit out file data
dot size and we'll do it a new line here
so let's go ahead and run that or build
it and then run it and we get an 11 so
we are grabbing this last line as a zero
because there's nothing there so it just
grabs a new line and of course temp is
initialized to zero so it just ends up
putting 0 there so I think what we do
here is
there's I don't know could just could
just do it here
the easiest way is to probably just do
it above this once that's kind of a a
pre thing or we could just do a check
and make sure it's not zero or we could
just do one last I don't know this is
fine I'm not gonna worry about it I'll
just say well we do want to know let me
think about this for a second this is a
rather easy problem actually I don't
know why I'm stumbling on it but okay
let's think about this and analyze the
problem which we already have we need to
hit the end of file to get out of this
loop so it doesn't hit the end of file
necessarily when we have a new line like
this so if we do this that will hit into
file we have this new line at the end it
is a bit of a problem for this
particular logic so let's just get rid
of that line for now and run it again
and now we get the proper result because
it does end of law it does end of file
on this last read rather than going to
that new line yeah there's many
different ways we can handle that we can
make sure it's not zero we can make sure
it actually grabs something I can't I
kind of forget how I used to always
handle this problem but I feel like I
would do one last
and and grab the data one more time or
something or do it the first time and or
use a do-while and check at the end of
the loop before doing pushback or
something like that as we could
essentially do this let's make this and
make it do here well yeah it should work
better right I might be wrong I messed
with this stuff in a while this is
pretty normal for programming though
it's a take to you a couple trial and
errors to get things perfect so don't be
too discouraged if something doesn't go
perfectly right the first time just take
note of where your mistake was and and
do it again okay so no this isn't
actually happy okay whatever I'm just
gonna leave it you get the point though
so let's say we want to take this data
and we want to process it like yeah we
got the data there but what if we want
to get the average we could do that we
could just say okay well we got the size
of the data of 10 right and we could
just add them all up and divide it by 10
so we could do a declare a float of
total we'll just call it total than
equal to zero
and we'll just do another for loop
little copypasta here basically you
could just process the data however you
want once you have it and
let's see what would we do here we would
add it up when you do total we can do a
plus equals and then whatever it is that
location be an eye here and maybe we
only want to do it if file data at I is
not equal zero and there we go just put
some brackets around this real quick so
it looks a little nicer correct the
formatting okay there we go
people are gonna rage it might like
coding in this I feel very sloppy but
don't worry it will work and then at the
end once we have that all totaled out
okay another thing with this not equals
zero you never know what it floats gonna
be it the not equals zero doesn't always
work so you usually want to be like
greater than usually want to put some
limits on it I wanted to be greater than
this negative and less than C make sure
that's a float with the F on the end so
essentially we're clamping it here
so rather than equals zero because a
float can have these little hanging last
numbers we're doing this clamp method of
it needs to be greater than this and
less than this so really close to zero
if it it's really close to zero or zero
we're not gonna process it but this only
process is if it is that so we're gonna
do the opposite of that with a knot
so if it's not zero basically we'll add
it to the total and maybe some of these
end up being zero like this is a zero
for example we don't want to process
that one and we also don't want to
process the end line if we end up having
that and in our weird logic of not doing
it perfect here we know that we get a
size of 11 when we have this this in
line and we could correct that up here
but if we don't want to worry about it
more just say we're getting rid of all
zeros we could do this but then as you
may know from doing an average we don't
want to divide by those zero spots too
since we're not counting them so we
would want something else like a count
and any time it finds one we'll just
increment this cow with plus plus then
at the very end we'll just spit it out
so we'll do a float the result equals
total / count and now we'll just want to
spit this out result or I will say
average and then we'll just spit out a
result here we'll put a new new line
here make it look a little fancier and
there we are we're processing some data
from the file oh I don't have to make
run bill just this here
let's see data read oh I need a new line
somewhere here - to make it break up
this code a little bit I'll just do it
right here so I want to do it a make I'm
gonna do and an to just say run this
afterwards so this is just a command
line thing you do I'll say do that
afterwards so you can kind of do things
in a row so tread in all our data and it
grab the average and and we could say
more stuff in here too because maybe we
want to know how many were actually
processing that one zero and now I'm
just kind of getting into getting in
deep what do we want to say here we'll
say count and notice about this count
number so I'll do that same command make
and run and we see that's nine which is
correct nine nonzero ones so that's just
a way you can pull in data and process
it do math on it whatever you want to do
with it
all your fancy logic okay so let's talk
a little about writing to a file and for
this I'm I'm just gonna put all this
code way lower and we're gonna talk a
little bit about writing to a file well
you know what let's just take this
result we have rather than all these C
outs will write these two files so up
here before we do any C outs there's our
first C out here well we'll do it before
this here let's declare an Ostrom or an
output file stream of stream well we'll
just call it out very simple a lot of
people like to declare all their
variables at the top before they use
them but I'm just doing it as it becomes
necessary and instead of all these C
outs I'm going to replace them with outs
but first we do need to open a file
so I'll say out dot open and let's make
a file here here what do we want to call
it I don't know we have an N dot txt so
let's make an out text and that should
open and create the file if one is
already created it will overwrite it now
you can change this to like an append
mode I can't remember how to do this off
the top of my head right here welcome to
google it if you want to do it but there
are modes for opening files where you
just append to the current file if it
already exists and that way you can keep
stacking up data but by default it will
just overwrite it and we'll create it if
it's not already made so the work world
and Internet is your oyster if you want
to do other special opens that handle
and in ways that aren't just overwrite
and creative not made already like you
can there's a mode where you can have it
throw an error if it's already made and
stuff like that okay
so now that we have this open let's do
an assert and we'll just assert that out
is open so that way our program will
crash if this returns false and assert
is an assert dot H and that's from I
think the old C libraries but basically
that you can throw this in when you're
debugging to make sure your code it'll
just crash on you if it gets to this and
it fails so if this returns false we're
gonna get a crash at line 34 so it's
just a quick way of uh not going further
if things are buggy we're gonna turn all
these C outs and to just out every C out
oh we don't need the standard anymore
because this is our own file not from
the standard standard library or our own
object that we're creating this one's
fine though cuz that's just an error one
so now we're not gonna get any terminal
output when we rebuild this and run it
it's just gonna be empty but we'll
notice that we have a new file and all
the things are here in our new file and
just as well after you write a file you
could read it back in doing these same
methods that's gonna do it for me in
this video for the basics of reading and
writing to files thank you for watching
hope you learned something feel free to
leave a comment and a like to help me
get noticed or if you really hated this
video please tell me why I know I had a
little fumble in there but hey that's
the nature of programming I could have
thought about that a little more before
I hit and record but hey you'll have
that so catch you in the next episode
and keep on coding don't get too
discouraged and appreciate all my
viewers out there I know I don't have a
lot right now but I'm gonna keep doing
this anyway so I really enjoy doing it
and I think it's worth worth doing and
if you're still around maybe you are
somewhat interested and in help it out
and let me know what I can do to make
these videos more watchable if you're
having trouble watching them a lot of
people say my voice puts people to sleep
and yeah I get that every girlfriend
I've ever had and said that too so I
don't really know what to do about that
other than then pretend to be more
excited or something or or hiding my
voice alright peace out guys catch you
in the next episode